hey guys Pete here going to do a quick
video today about the hound and the Lord
of Light primarily talked about stuff
that's happened in the past and his
vision in episode 1 of season 7 - really
no spoilers beyond that so ahead of
episode 3 I was thinking back to episode
1 - one of the things that stood out to
me and that was this Hound business and
the fact that he saw a vision in the
flames not because of what he saw
necessarily as I'm sure that a lot of
people been discussing that already but
what's more interesting to me is the
fact that he's having visions at all and
that the Brotherhood probably should
have had some idea about this already
for what it's worth I think the visions
are pretty straightforward outside of
the statement that says there's a
mountain that looks like an arrowhead I
mean the wall is the wall and the castle
is eastwatch-by-the-sea there's not too
much mystery in that at all the mountain
part and the fact that they added that
frozen waves that aren't necessarily
clear like they cut that out when he
says it in the show but they printed it
on the website but I guess the best
theory I've heard about the mountain
shaped like an arrowhead is the mountain
of dragonglass that Sam refers to at
Dragonstone
now I'm not completely excited about
this but it makes more sense than some
of the other things that are out there
so it could be a reference to something
we don't know about yet and yeah it's
just whatever for the record I don't
think that it has to do with Samuel his
brother the mountain and I don't think
that basically because I don't think his
purpose and the story is to kill him
anymore
I mean he's always thought that was his
purpose but I don't think it really
makes a lot of sense at this point going
forward either way the fact that he is
seeing visions is kind of bizarre I mean
it gives him a good story and pushes him
into a place where he becomes a very
important character and I'm fine with
that I mean I don't have a problem with
that
especially because of his being burned
as a child and this gave him like this
insane fear of flame that he's had he's
been a certifiable killer and
just a cruel kind of man his whole life
for the most part and so in this world
isn't a bad thing when a character gets
to redeem themselves my interest lies in
the ability itself and the Brotherhood
without banners and their intentions the
reason why it stands out is because
we've seen in the trailers quite a bit
that these guys are going to be teamed
up with John at some point north of the
wall you know one of the biggest things
that we saw in the and the winners here
trailer was that dramatic shot of
barrack was his burning sword so that is
going to happen and we know from season
six that that was their intention when
they ran into the Hound in the first
place no way back in season three they
had Aria and Gendry and they end up
catching the Hound and instead of just
killing him they give him a trial by
combat where he fights beric Dondarrion
so in that short bit of time you know we
find out that they're still hanging out
because they're trying to kill his
brother you know there's that back and
forth that exchange where he says you
fight for ghosts because they say that
Ned had told them to go out and kill the
mountain and Ned and Robert have long
been dead at this point he find out that
they're really into the Lord of Light
now and Thoros has always been like he
arrives in King's Landing
for that reason more or less he was a
bad priest they sent him to King's
Landing to recruit people to make the
story really simple when he got there he
was more into the idea of drinking and
everything else so he didn't do a very
good job but either way he has visions
in the flame as well he sees things and
he's also been able to bring beric back
to life which we all know about that so
it's a little bit odd that they give him
a trial which he beats barrack and
single combat and then he's free to go
letting him go isn't we're at that point
because in their minds as religious
people the Lord of Light has spoken and
he's saying that the hounds all right so
my thought was this is their motivation
because they think or Thoreau's has seen
something that tells them that he is
important because if they if he had
and we know that the divisions aren't
exactly clear all the time
this could be a good reason to have him
fight Barrack who they know they can
bring back anyways most likely so they
set up this trial by combat the hound
comes out Thoreau springs back back to
life and that's their answer to whether
or not the hound is important in that
scenario what's also weird here is that
he ends up taking Aria after she runs
away and you know they were looking for
her initially but they sort of just
leave it go now all this stuff could be
inconsequential so I don't want to
ramble on about it but I do think it's
interesting that he had this vision we
can presume that Thoreau's has had
similar visions and that he may have
seen some bigger importance for the
hound which got them in the same place
now the whole idea whether the Lord of
Light real or is real or not is up for
debate I mean the magic is real we know
that because we've seen it we know
there's magic involved like these these
are things are actually happening but we
don't know if there's a supernatural
entity that's in charge or but something
else and then I went into all this in my
are the gods real series so I won't
rehash it now but it's something to
think about if you think about it we saw
in the trailers that there were going to
be up north we know we've seen Derek and
the Hound those fighting up there we can
imagine that they all make it there so
you figure there's like three Lord of
Light devotees that are going to be
fighting at John's side now how many of
them are actually going to live that's
the question
but it also brings up this idea that
Varrick has that kiss of life and I've
always been skeptical that he might use
it on John because I just don't think
they're going to kill John again but
there is the thing where maybe the Hound
dies and then maybe back would bring him
back I don't know there's a lot of stuff
that can happen when you have magic like
this involved so we'll see where the
Hound goes with this we don't know they
need to full convert yet but he
definitely saw a vision from what we can
tell he's definitely with the
Brotherhood and they're headed north so
hopefully we'll see them all together
sooner rather than later all right
please like the video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
have it yet I will be doing the trailer
breakdown for for later when it comes
out plus recap and review for episode 3
and basically the same schedule I did
last week so definitely set your
notifications on my channel after you
subscribe and check back because there's
always new stuff coming out thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon
you